In this challenge episode
We’ll try the world’s
stickiest table tennis rubber
Ping pong with
a remote controlled car
And more
Let’s get into it
C’mon Emil
That’s too easy
Try this one!
Moving target
Welcome to this challenge episode
We asked you guys on Instagram
What challenges we could do
with a remote controlled car?
Okay!
Let’s go monster truck!
Forehand loop!
We need to play with the wheel next
I actually think
it’s going to be very good spin
Do you want topspin or...
backspin?
You can choose
What a spin!
Yes!
Okay, Emil
Sidespin
Oh, oh!
How is the spin that good actually?
It got a shot on!
We built our own table tennis robot
from remote controlled cars
I’m pretty sure this won’t go well
Nice!
It actually works
We will release ten and let’s see
how many you can get
Okay!
Full gas!
No!
It’s going too fast!
Emil!
You didn’t get many shots on
Was it a success?
I’m not sure
Normal table tennis robot is better
Yeah!
It needs a rest
Just like that!
It was nice!
Nice slice!
Good one!
Otto, Otto, Otto, Otto
Otto, are you ready
to make the world’s spinniest racket?
Yeah!
Can we start off
with the normal rubber
and then try to see
if we can make even spinnier rubber?
Yeah!
It’s like a dead fish!
Is it really that bad?
It’s the world’s stickiest rubber
that’s legal to play with
Let’s glue it on
And a layer on
the Pongfinity Sensei blade
Then we cut it
Let’s take off the protective layer
The world’s slowest peel
The intensity!
Okay!
The first bounce test
One
Two
Three
Bounces quite a lot still
Let’s see the stick test
It’s not even sticky!
Maybe you just need to
push it a bit harder
Yeah!
Just more power
More power!
Honey next?
More!
The honey bear wants more honey
The smell is really interesting
Yeah!
We’ve got it stickier
Put spin on it
I got honey in my face!
I think it’s going to get stickier
the more it dries
Okay, drop it!
Yeah!
It’s more absorbed
Now it’s only one bounce
Now we have it
Let’s try a slow shot first
Now you can just drop it
It’s coming!
Now it didn’t stick
It’s sometimes sticky
Sometimes not
You try and play with it
Yes!
It’s so slow!
It’s like five times slower
than your normal shot
Let’s come up with
something new
Dried up handball wax
Very tasty!
It sticks quite well
It’s definitely an improvement
But you still can’t make
spin with it
Next up glue
We need more, Otto!
We are trained professionals
But we don’t know
what we are doing
That’s like minus bounces
Let’s try and play with it
Hmm...
Some spin!
Give me your hardest loop
I hit it!
It was so fast
You couldn’t see it!
Xu Xin ball catch
Wow!
That was crazy!
That was way better
than Xu Xin
World’s stickiest racket
A snowman!
If you want to do this
Alright, Emil
I think we’re going to
destroy these guys
Definitely!
They’ll have no chance!
Nice!
You got it, Emil!
You!
Nice!
Good one!
Nice rally!
Nice one!
Not nice enough
What?
Along the wall!
Nobody noticed anything
Why is nobody serving short?
That’s true actually
That’s why!
It worked!
We got it!
That was perfect
You go!
(Miikka) I can’t reach!
(Benedek) What you mean
you can’t reach?
I trusted him
Very nice!
Oh my goodness!
That was good!
Emil!
That’s your side
Change!
Nice!
What a backhand!
Okay, that was good!
Thank you!
Good!
Just in case
I have a deja-vu
but in the right side now
You!
Good edge!
I hate table tennis!
Good game!
Good fight!
Try to hit the cup
C’mon, Miikka!
You can do better
I lose!
High five!
Try and catch me!
No!
It was already in!
C’mon!
Victory!
Are we ready?
We are ready!
No!
That didn’t count!
It did count!
No, it didn’t!
Yes it did!
I’m going steady
No!
Emil, you have a better
roof than me
It’s coming home
“Much better roof”
You’re just driving much worse
No, it’s the roof!
The one who knocks
the other one over wins
No!
The champion!
Okay, Miikka!
Give me the controller
Not yet!
We haven’t been driving enough
I can’t come up with anything